[موسيقى]
ام
لم يعد للحروب الشكل ذاته وليس بالضروره
ان تعلن في سماع فوق المدافع والرصاص
العالم يتغير ومعه تتغير لعبه بسط النفوذ
والسيطره ويرتفع ثمنها
هذه الحروب تدور عن شواطئ القاره السمراء
في صراع محتدم على موانئها فحركه التجاره
العالميه لا تنظر ولا تتوقف وفي سبيل
السيطره على خطوط الملاحه العالميه تسارع
الدول الى حجز مواقع لها على الخارطه وباي
ثمن ولاي ثم ان تنافس دول مثل الصين
والامارات وتركيا وقطر
في هذا الفيلم نقف عند المسافه الصدر من
كوارث الصراع ونجوم بين اكثر موانئ القرن
الافريقي اهميه استراتيجيه
لتفكيك مشهد حرب الموانئ
ام
[موسيقى]
لتوها وصلت قيمه السنغافوريه الى ميناء
دورا ليل الحاويات في جيبوتي المركز
التجاري الرئيس لشرق قاره افريقيا
حركه دؤوبه على مدار اربع وعشرين ساعه
لا تتوقف طوال العام يستقبل الميناء نحو
ثمانمائه وخمسين الف حاويه سنويا
وقال احصاءات البنك الدولي الذي يعتبر
موانئ جيبوتي من اكثر الموانئ تطورا في
العالم
كما صنفت منظمه التجاره العالميه جيبوتي
رابع افضل دوله افريقيه قامت ب تحسين
قدراتها لربط الدول ببعضها شرقا وغربا
بالتوازي مع التوسع الاقتصادي وارتفاع
معدلات النمو لشركتها التجاريه الرئيسيه
اثيوبيا التي تربطها بن وان جيبوتي سكه
حديد نقل البضائع التي تسافر منها واليها
جيبوتي واحده من اصغر دور القرن الافريقي
وتقع على الساحل الشرقي لا ينقل الافريقي
اربعه دول جيبوتي حيث نقف اريتريا الصومال
واثيوبيا
تبلغ مساحه جيبوتي ثلاثه وعشرين الفا
ومائتي كيلومتر مربع ويبلغ عدد سكانها
حوالي تسعمائه الف نسمه
تقع عند المدخل الجنوبي للبحر الاحمر
وتشكل جسر بين الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا
تحدها من الشمال اريتيريا بينما تحيطها
اثيوبيا من الجهتين الشماليه الغربيه
والغربيه الجنوبيه ويحدث الصومال من الجهه
الجنوبيه الشرقيه
وفي الشرق منها باب المندب وخليج عدن هذا
ما جعل جيبوتي بوابه شحن هامه للسلع التي
تدخل وتخرج من مرتفعات شرق افريقيا و تلك
الشحنات المتبادله بين اوروبا والشرق
الاوسط واسيا
نحو خمسه وعشرين لثلاثين في المائه من
التجاره الدوليه ت عبر البحر الاحمر من
خلال باب المندب القريب من موالينا لذلك
نريد ان نحصل على حصه كبيره من هذه النسبه
على الاقل من حجم اعمال اعاده الشاحنه من
خلال سواحلنا
منذ استقلال اريتيريا عام الف وتسعمائه
وثلاثه وتسعين
وبقت ان اثيوبيا منفذها البحريه الوحيده
على البحر الاحمر عمل الجيبوتي على توسيع
البنيه التحتيه ل موانئها لتلبيه احتياجات
اثيوبيا التي يزيد عدد سكانها عن مائه
مليون نسمه
وعليه او كل الجيبوتي في العام الفين
اداره مينائها القديم الى ميناء دبي
الدولي الذي عرض فيما بعد شركه موانئ دبي
العالميه
لاحقا اسس تجيبوتي في العام الفين وسته
امينا دورا لي للحاويات بشراكه مع موانئ
دبي التي قامت بتصميمه وبناءه وتشغيله بعد
منح امتياز ا اخر استحوذت به على ثلاثه
وثلاثين في المائه من حصه الميناء لمده
ثلاثين عاما بينما احتفظت حكومه جيبوتي
بالباقي
افتتح ميناء دولي للحاويات في عام الفين
وتسعه
كما استقبل يوميا بمتوسط سفينتين احيانا
فلاتر سفن واحيانا واحد لكن المتوسطه
وسفينه يوميه
ناحيه الخدمات اللوجيستيه التي يوفرها
الميناء الخدمه التي نقدمها هنا الى السفن
التي تاتينا هي تفريغها وتحويلها في الوقت
المحدد ثم تتجه السفينه الى منع اخر
التفريغ واعاده الشحن هي هدفنا الاساسي
ونحرص على ان تقدم الخدمه في اقل وقت ممكن
اذا حققنا ذلك يكون كلا الطرفين راضيين
بعد ذلك غادر السفينه ونقوم بالقمه
اللوجيستيه التاليه وهي نقل الحاويات الى
اماكن التخزين المخصصه لها ومن ثم توصيلها
الى العميل سواء في جيبوتي او اثيوبيا هذه
اهم الخدمه اللوجيستيه التي نقدمها في
الميناء انفقت جيبوتي على الميناء نحو
تسعين مليون دولار ضمن راس مال قدره
مائه وثلاثه وثلاثون مليون دولار بينما
دفعت شركه موانئ دبي نحو خمسه واربعين
مليون دولار وفق العقد المبرم بينهما اي
الخدمات اللوجستيه
الاكثر دخلا للميناء
لدينا في ثلاثه انواع من الزبائن العمل
المحلي والعمل الاقليمي الذي ياتي من
الدول المجاوره
وبشكل رئيس اثيوبيا والعمل الدولي الخاص
باعاده الشهر لذلك بالنسبه لدخل الميناء
فانه يعتمد على حجم الخدمات المقدمه
اليوم حجم الاعمال الاكبر ياتينا من تجاره
اثيوبيا تليها جيبوتي واخيرا اعمال اعاده
الشان الدولي
هدفنا الاستراتيجي في المستقبل هو زياده
اعمال اعاده الشان الدولي لا ندخلها اكبر
بكثير من المحللين والاقامه
من اجل منافسه موانئ اخرى كبيره على البحر
الاحمر مثل ميناء جده السعودي الذي يتسع
اربعه ملايين حاويه على المحيط الهندي
مثل ميناء صلاله في عمان الذي تبلغ سته
ثلاثه ملايين ونصف مليون حاويه
تطمح جيبوتي الى رفع كفاءه وقدره موانئها
لتتحول الى مركز اعاده شحن دولى فى المقام
الاول كونها تنفرد بموقع استراتيجي لا
تتمتع به موانئ اخرى تعتمد على نشاط اعاده
الشحن مثل ميناء جبل علي في الامارات الذي
يستحوذ على حصه الاسد بطاقه استيعابيه
تبلغ اثنين وعشرين مليون حاويه سنويا لكن
طموح جيبوتي قوبل على ما يبدو برفض من قبل
شركه ها موانئ دبي التي عارضت انشاء موانئ
اخرى على الساحل الجيبوتي مثل ميناء دولي
متعدد الاغراض الممتده من بناء دوله
للحاويات
وهدف حكومه جيبوتي هو تقديم حلول لوجستيه
متكامله بالعميل كان ل جيبوتي ميناء واحد
الان خلال عشر سنوات اصبح لديها خمسه
موانئ جديده بالاضافه الى سكه حديد اخرى
في الطريق
لذلك تقدم وجيبوتي حلولا متكامله الى دول
الجوار من اجل تقديم خدمات افضل
انشئ الميناء المتعدد الاطراف بهدف تلبيه
الخدمات اللوجيستيه لدى سفن الشحن وحاويات
النفط بتكلفه تتجاوز نصف مليار دولار لعمل
تمديدات للميناء تصل الى خمسه عشر مرسل
لاستيعاب النمو المتوقع في حركه المرور
وبقدره للتعامل مع تسعه وعشرين مليون طن
سنويا
وهو جزء من استثمار مشترك من قبل ميناء
جيبوتي وشركه ميرتس الصينيه
الاختلاف بين الميناء القديم وهذا الميناء
و اننا غيرنا نظام التشغيل بالكامل في
الميناء القديم كان لدينا شركات خاصه تقوم
بتشغيل الميناء ولكن لا تقدم افضل الخدمات
في هذا الميناء الجديد وضعنا الكثير من
الاستثمارات في البنى التحتيه والمعدات
ونظام التشغيل من اجل اداره العمليه بشكل
كامل هو تقديم خدمه افضل للزبائن وهذا هو
سبب ادارتنا للميناء بشكل مباشر بدلا من
الاستعانه بشركات خاصه وهذا اختلاف كبير
من حيث الخدمه والجوده امان البضائع
والانتاجيه
الخطط المستقبليه
المشروع القادم لهذا الميناء هو انشاء
رصيف جديد من اجل بعض البضائع التي لا
يمكن تحويلها من الميناء القديم مثل الفحم
والماشيه
مارس
يضاف الى ذلك انشاء منطقه حره تقول جيبوتي
انها الاكبر في افريقيا بتكلفه تبلغ ثلاثه
مليارات ونصف مليار دولار انشات الصين
ولحقت بها تركيا
ومع ازدياد حده المنافسه وانفتاح جيبوتي
على كل الدول للاستثمار على اراضيها
تصاعدت الخلافات مع الامارات وصلت ذروتها
عندما قرر الجيبوتي بالعام الفين وثمانيه
عشر تجري شركه موانئ دبي من امتيازها بسبب
تعارضه مع المصالح الاساسيه للدوله على حد
قولها
استند القرار على قانون اقره البرلمان في
فبراير الفين وسبعه عشر ومنح الحكومه سلطه
انهاء العقد مع مشغل الميناء في دبي
لجات الشركه الاماراتيه الى التحكيم
الدولي في لندن وكتبت الجوله بعد ان قضت
المحكمه بان حكومه جيبوتي تصرفت بشكل غير
شرعي عندما انهت العقد من جانب واحد في
فبراير الفين وثمانيه عشر
مبررات فسخ العقد مع شركه موانئ دبي تثير
التعجب لفرض انتهاكه للسياده جيبوتي فان
كانت الحكومه قبل منح الامتياز بهذا الشكل
من البدايه عام الفين وسته وما قبل
قررت مواجهه ممثلي حكومه جيبوتي الذي وقع
العقد ابو بكر عمر الذي يشغل حاليا منصب
رئيس موانئ جيبوتي هل كنتم تتوقعون ان يصل
الخلاف
في الحقيقه لا تفاوض مع شركه موانئ دبي
قرابه اربع سنوات لحثهم على تغيير موقفهم
والقبول بعمل تعديل طفيف على العقد
بالطريقه الطبيعيه التي اسست عليها الشركه
وشكل بها مجلس الاداره
[موسيقى]
وبطريقه المعتاده لاصحاب الاسهم الاكبر ك
اصوات اغلبيه في المجلس
لكن في هذا العقد كان حيث نصر على ان
حكومه جيبوتي لا يحق لها تطوير اي بنى
تحتيه بحريه او اي موانئ على طول الساحل
الجيبوتي كاملا ولمده خمسين عاما
لذلك لم يكن هذا مقبولا من قبل الحكومه
كيف لشركه ان تعيق مستقبل شعب باكمله او
ان تاخذه رهينه لديها لمده خمسين عاما
لذلك حاولت حكومه جيبوتي تصحيح الوضع لكن
موانئ دبي رفض ذلك بشكل قاطع وقالت ان هذا
العقد جيد وسنبقى عليه هكذا
اذا كان العقد منذ البدايه في هذا
الانتهاك
لسيادتكم السؤال لماذا قبلتم لماذا وقعت
منذ البدايه
كما تعلمون عندما تتفاوض للمره الاولى حول
العقد صغير
القليله تحدث مثل هذه الاخطاء الفائز
لكن ان وقع ذلك مع شريك بحسن نيه فيجب ان
جلسه سويا و تصحح الوضع في اللحظه التي
تدرك فيها ان العقد غير موزونه وغير عادل
شعبيته
الى شركه واطلب منه تصريح بعض الجنود في
العقد ان
[موسيقى]
احد المصادر اخبرني ان جيبوتي استعانت
بشركه محاماه دوليه لاخذ مشوره قانونيه
قبل تسع عقدها مع شركه موانئ دبي
بحسب المصدر امضى مكتب المحاماه الدولي
اشهر اعده في جمع الادله لاثبات ان موانئ
دبي رفضت طلبات من شركات توريد لاستخدام
ميناء دوليه للحاويات في جيبوتي تشير بعض
هذه الادله الى ان الشركه الاماراتيه
اعتادت الادعاء بان القدرات اللوجيستيه في
محطه دوليه قد تم تجاوزها
وتطلب من شركات الشحن اعاده توجيه شحناتها
الى الامارات عبر ميناء جبل علي وميناء
خالد في الشارقه الامر الذي اكده رئيس
موانئ جيبوتي
اه
من الواضح ان هذه الاستراتيجيه شركه موانئ
دبي عندما تكون مشغل موانئ دولي في منطقه
واحده من الطبيعي كما هو حال شركات تجهيل
الموانئ الكبيره الا تاخذ اكثر من ميناء
واحد في نفس المنطقه لكن ما تقوم به موانئ
دبي هنا في البحر الاحمر انها اخذت اكثر
من خمسه موعدا
الدليل الاخر ان من الحاويات الذي ينازعون
عليه اليوم وبنى في عام الفين وثمانيه مع
سعه مليون وستمائه الف حاويه قبل انشاء
هذا الميناء بين الفين وسته والفين
المانيا كانت الطاقه الاستيعابيه لتجاره
اثيوبيا وجيبوتي تقدر بمائه وخمسين الف
حاويه
لماذا اذن ان شان هذا الميناء بطاقه
استيعابيه تعادل احد عشر بعد هذا الرقم
بالتاكيد لان ما استهدف نشاط اعاده الشان
الدولي وبالفعل بدانا هذا النشاط وكانت
السفن تاتي الينا وتفضل اعاده نقل
الحاويات من خلال جيبوتي لكن موانئ دبي
كانت تعارض ذلك برفع اسعار الخدمات
المقدمه في جيبوتي فيما يتعلق باعاده
الشحن وتحويل البضائع بعد مغادرتهم باسبوع
واحد من الثاني والعشرين من فبراير الفين
وثمانيه عشر ارسلت لنا شركه بي اي الاسرا
ريال شحن ثلاثمائه الف حاويه لاعاده شحن
وهذا دليل اخر من اجل زياده اثنين وثلاثين
في المائه من اعمال الميناء عليك بالعمل
الجاد والقيام بالتسويق المطلوب على مدار
عام او عام ونصف
وهذا ما حدث ببساطه وهذا هو الدليل ان بعد
مغادرتهم اتجاه كل الحواجز
مشكلتهم ليست حول هذا الميناء انما حول
تطوير البلد كله وهذا ما تم الجهود من اجل
اه بيانات تقرير البنك الدولي اكدت ايضا
ان عاده الحاويات التي تصل الى ميناء
دولار سنويا
لم يصل الى سعته التخزينيه المفترضه اي
مليون ومائتي الف حاويه وهو ما يفند ايضا
ادعاءات شركه موانئ دبي بان القدره
الاستيعابيه لميناء دوليه قد تم تجاوزها
كنت باجراء اتصال مع شركه موانئ دبي
العالميه وهي واحده من كبريات شركات
الموانئ وتدير عمليات في اكثر من اربعين
ميناء حول العالم معظمها مراكز شحن مزدحمه
مثل لندن و روتردام
مديره الاتصال بشركه موانئ دبي
اه انا اسمي سلام هنداوي و عم بعمل اه
فيلم عن موانئ البحر الاحمر ومضيق باب
المندب ونحنا بنعرف انه شركه موانئ دبي
مستحوذا على عدد كبير من الموانئ بها
المنطقه الاستراتيجيه
وكان عندي بعض الاسئله وحب اسالهم لحضرتك
قناه الجزيره اعتبرت المتحدثه باسم الشركه
عن عدم اجراء المقابله على الهاتف
اه صرحنا اه اجريت العديد من المقابلات في
جيبوتي في الصومال وبيهم جدا انه يكون
موجود راي الشركه يعني هذه الاتهامات
موجهه الكم وهي اتهامات كبيره
من او للاخبار
انا عم بعطيك الحق الرد
انا راح راح ابعتلك الاسئله
شكرا جزيلا لك خلال فتره انتاج الفيلم لم
اتلق اي رد من شركه موانئ دبي على اسئلتنا
ومن بينها لماذا رفضت الشركات اعاده النظر
في بنود العقد التي تمنع جيبوتي من بناء
وتطوير الموانئ اخرى ولماذا ازداد عدد
السفن التي تصل الى ميناء دورا له
للحاويات منذ فسخ عقد الشركه
وكانت الشركه الاماراتيه قد اصدرت بيانات
عده استنكرت فيها قرار حكومه جيبوتي فسخ
عقد ميناء دورا ليه للحاويات وقالت ان
الحكومه سيطرت بطريقه غير شرعيه على
الميناء
منذ ان تم فسخ عقد شركه موانئ دبي تسابق
دول عده مثل فرنسا وسنغافوره وكندا
للاستحواذ على محطه دورا للحاويات لكن من
الواضح ان جيبوتي تتفق في الصين كما ترى
الصين في جيبوتي بوابه تجاريه هامه ضمن
مشروعها الطموح طريق الحرير ذلك المشروع
الذي تضع فيه الصين مئات المليارات
للاستثمار في البنى التحتيه العملاقه من
طرق سريعه و سكه حديديه ومرافق بحريه
لاكثر من خمس وستين دوله سيعبر من خلالها
الطريق برا وبحرا بدءا من جنوب المحيط
الهادئ مرورا بدول الشرق الاوسط وشرق
افريقيا وصولا الى اقصى شمال القاره
الاوروبيه
مشكله جيبوتي الذاتي على الارجح مما يمكن
ان نصفه بانقلاب الجغرافيه السياسيه في
القرن الافريقي
هذا الانقلاب بدات الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وايضا اسرائيل ومصر والسعوديه
والامارات
والهدف هو منع تقدم الصين نحو افريقيا
ونقطه من دخول الرئيس بالتاكيد هي جيبوتي
جيبوتي
[موسيقى]
معظم مشاريع انشاء وتوزيعات الموانئ
استحوذت عليها الصين المنافس الشرس
للامارات في القرن الافريقي فكلاهما ينظر
لجهود كمفتاح من اجل الوصول الى الدول
الافريقيه الحديثه
لم تكتفي الصين بتطوير البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ والسكك الحديديه والمطارات في
جيبوتي بل قامت بانشاء اول قاعده عسكريه
لها خارج حدود الصين تظل جيبوتي ايضا
قواعد عسكريه ل فرنسا والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واليابان
ومنظمه حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتو بالاضافه
الى قوات اجنبيه اخرى لمكافحه القرصنه
كما كانت للامارات قاعده عسكريه قبل ان
يندلع خلاف بين الطرفين طردت على اثره
الامارات من جيبوتي وادى ذلك الى قطع
العلاقات الديبلوماسيه بينهما و كبديل عن
القاعده والميناء اللذين خسارتهما في
جيبوتي اتجاهات الامارات الى اريتيريا و
وقعت اتفاقا في الفين وخمسه عشر تستخدم
بموجبه ميناء ومطار عصب على البحر الاحمر
لمده ثلاثين عاما وينص الاتفاق على ان
تدفع دبي مقابل سنويا للسلطات الاريتريه
اضافه الى ثلاثين في المائه من دخل
الموانئ بعد تشغيلها
لكن صور اقمار صناعيه حصلنا عليها كشفت ان
المنطقه التي استحوذت عليها الامارات منذ
الفين وخمسه عشر لم تخضع لاي اعمال توسيعه
او انشاءات لتطوير نشاط الميناء التجاري
بل تحولت الى ثكنات عسكريه اماراتيه تنطلق
منها طائراتها ضمن عمليات التحالف السعودي
الاماراتي في اليمن
وفي الصوره الملتقطه في الحادي والعشرين
من نوفمبر الفين وثمانيه عشر لمن رفض اي
وجود لحاويات او سفن تجاريه في ميناء عصب
وبدلا من ذلك كانت هناك ثلاث عشره سفينه
منها احدى عشره عسكريه واثنتان للنقل
الحربي
اما ميناء مطار عصابه التابع للامارات
ايضا فقد رصدنا فيه عشرات السفن اغلبها
لعمليات النقل العسكري والباقي سوف قتاليه
يضاف الى ذلك ما اخبرتنا به مصادر خاصه
بان هناك سجنا سريا يقع على السواحل
الايرانيه ضمن النطاق المستاجر بواسطه
الامارات
[موسيقى]
اكد فريق تحليل صور الاقمار الصناعيه وجود
سجن في منطقه ساحليه بين ميناء مطار عصب
تبلغ مساحته اربعمائه وسبعه عشر الف متر
مربع ويضم غرفا تحت الارض وهو ما يعني
احتمال استخدام السجن في عمليات الاخفاء
القسري المتهمه بها الامارات من قبل
المنظمات الدوليه خاصه مع وجود تقارير
حقوقيه تستند على شهادات لاهالي الضحايا
عن ترحيل معتقلين يمنيين الى سجون خارج
اليمن ربما يكشف ذلك ايضا الاحداث
الحقيقيه وراء سعي الامارات الى توسيع
نفوذها البحري في منطقه باب المندب
تريد الامارات النفوذ
وتحاول اما ان تضم الموانئ عليها
محلها
لذلك تستخدم الامارات
والناعمه القوه العسكريه وقوه شركه موانئ
دبي لتشتري هذه المواد
تستخدم القوتين ولديها افضليه في ذلك لذلك
كلمات فتفت الشركات الاقليميه وانقسمت وكل
ما افتقر النظام الاقليمي سياسه واحده
كلما زادت حده التنافس
وعلى الرغم من ان الخارطه العسكريه في
اليمن ليست ثابته او محسومه فان استماته
الامارات لبسط نفوذها على باقي المدن
اليمنيه المطله على البحر الاحمر باتت
حقيقه لا تقبل الشك وفق الخريطه فان
الامارات تبسط سيطرتها على اغلب موانئ
اليمن التجاري والنفطيه في محاوله منها ل
توسيع نفوذها على ضفتي مضيق باب المندب
دون وجود اي منافس لها لذلك لم يكن
مستغربا اندفاعها نحو الموانئ الصوماليه
ايضا
توجهت الى الصومال للاقتراب اكثر من هذه
الموانئ والوقوف على حقيقه ما جرى من
صفقات ترى الحكومه الصوماليه انها غير
شرعيه كان من الملفت حجم التحديات الامنيه
في شوارع مقديشو نقول يتطلب المرور عبر
عشرات الحواجز العسكريه
يتمتع الصومال با طول ساحل في افريقيا و
يطل على المحيط الهندي وخليج عدن
ويبلغ طوله ثلاثه الاف كيلو متر تتوزع على
سواحله اربعه موانئ رئيسه هي ميناء
العاصمه مقديشو حيث نقف و ميناء كسمايو في
اقليم جوبا لاند وميناء بوصاصو في
بونتلاند و ميناء بربره في اقليم ارض
الصومال
في سبتمبر الفين واربعه عشر انت قلت مهم
اداره ميناء مقديشو الى شركه بيراك
التركيه بموجب عقد ابرمته الحكومه
الصوماليه لمده عشرين عاما بحسب الاتفاق
فان خمسه واربعين في المائه من واردات
الميناء مخصصه لتطويره وتوسيع خدماته امام
السفن التجاريه لجذب حركه التجاره
العالميه
اما ميناء مصاص وبرا فقد استحوذت عليهما
شركه موانئ دبي في صفقات حامت حولها
الشبهات و اثارت خلافات حتى بين
الصوماليين انفسهم
تمكن فريقنا من الحصول على صور خاصه من
الميناءين الخاضعين للسيطره الاماراتيه
مدينه ساحليه تابعه لاقليم ارض الصومال
المطل على خليج عدن بطول نحو سبعمائه
كيلومتر اعلن الاقليم انفصاله عن الصومال
عام الف وتسعمائه وواحد وتسعين
ولم يحضى باي اعتراف دولي لكن الامارات
تتعامل مع الاقليم كدوله مستقله دون
الرجوع للحكومه الفيديراليه في مقديشيو
مشكله دبي ان هناك شعور بانه اذا تمكنت
الدول الاخرى المتنافسه في القرن الافريقي
من الخروج من هذا الصراع ستتنافس مع دبي
في تطوير مواليهم لذلك فان الطريقه
الوحيده لاجهاض ذلك اما التحكم في هذه
الموانئ او ربطها
الكونترول
في مايو الفين وخمسه عشر وقعت الامارات
مذكره تفاهم مع اقليم ارض الصومال
الانفصالي لتطوير ميناء بربره لحق الوصول
الى مطار المدينه الساحليه المطله على
مضيق باب المندب شمالي غرب الصومال كما
تظهر صوره فضائيه حصلنا عليها وجود قاعده
جويه وبحريه اماراتيه الى جانب المطار فقد
قبلت حكومه ارض الصومال في فبراير الفين
وسبعه عشر طالبا اماراتي للحصول على اذن
لفتح قاعده عسكريه لها في براء جاء هذا
الطلب في اعقاب الاستثمار الذي بلغت قيمته
اربعمائه واثنين واربعين مليون دولار لمده
ثلاثين عاما لشركه موانئ دبي لتحصل
الاخيره على حصه قدرها واحد وخمسون في
المائه من المشروع بينما تمتلك حكومه ارض
الصومال ثلاثين في المائه وكان لاثيوبيا
تسعه عشر في المائه قبل ان تنسحب لاحقا
اتفاق اخر ابرمته شركه موانئ دبي في ابريل
الفين وسبعه عشر مع اقليم بونتلاند شبه
المستقل حيث استحوذت الشركه الاماراتيه
على امتياز لمده ثلاثين عاما بقيمه
ثلاثمائه وسته وثلاثين مليون دولار لتطوير
واداره ميناء متعدد الاغراض في مدينه بوسو
التي تقع الى اقصى الشرق من برا
قابلت وزيره الموانئ والنقل البحري
الصوماليه مريم او يس جامع هل كان لديك
معلم حول اتفاقيه ميناء وخاصه وبربره اه
الصومالي
الحكومه الصوماليه بامكانها الحديث عن
الموضوع عندما تكون طرفا في الاتفاق لكن
نحن كحكومه فيديراليه سمعنا عبر المواقع
الالكترونيه بانه تم توقيع اتفاق بين
موانئ دبي العالميه وبين اداره صومال ان
بشان ميناء بربره وبالتالي فان الحكومه
الفيدراليه ليس لها اي دور في الاتفاق لكن
كانت رئيسه اه اه الموانع في الصومال ماذا
يقولون لك مسؤول الموانئ هناك اه ان تنزع
بدي ان
اه
وممثل للحكومه بشان الموانع فقد خسرنا هذه
الخطوه على انها انتهاك صارخ لسياده
الصومال ودستور البلاد وانها تريد قرار
وللعلم فالقضيه ليست خفيه او طي الكتمان
حيث اكد فخامه رئيس الجمهوريه السيد محمد
عبد الله بشكل علني على ترحيبه بكل الجهات
والمؤسسات المهتمه بالاستثمار النواب
وهذا يعني ان تتصل تلك الجهات مع الحكومه
الفيدراليه والوزارات المعنيه الى وزاره
قبله اليه او
ان ان ان اه
تابعتم عبر وسائل الاعلام باننا قمنا
بزياره الى كل من ميناء هو بيو
مع وفد كبير من دوله قطر بهدف الاستثمار
وتطوير عدد من الموالين لدى اه صوماليه
قد وضع الرئيس حجر الاساس
كنا نبحث عن شركاء لتطويره لكن الان هناك
خطه من المتوقع ان تقوم بها دوله قطر
لتطوير الميناء
يضعونها اه جهود واضح بدي اه
من انها قامت بالتنسيق والتعاون مع
الحكومه الفيدراليه بشان موضوع
اه
وهذا ما نريده من كل الجهات المهتمه
بالاستثمار في الصومال
ان نفهم ان
على عكس الشركات التركيه والقطريه التي
تستثمر في موانئ الصومال بالتنسيق مباشره
مع الحكومه الفيدراليه في مقديشيو يرى
الصومال ان الامارات عبرت الى موانئ ه من
الابواب الخلفيه
الخلافات بين الامارات وجيبوتي على ميناء
دورا ليه للحاويات بدات المفاوضات سرا بين
شركه موانئ دبي واقليم ارض الصومال في
يونيو الفين وثلاثه عشر عبر رجل جيبوتي
عبد الرحمان محمود دوريه الذي لجا الى
الامارات بعد نشوب خلافات بينه وبين حكومه
جيبوتي
وهو رد الاعمال
اذار
علاقته بربه
في علاقته مع
ابنه الرئيس السابق في الصومال وكان ممثل
الصومال الى ان لدى دوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده وبما ان ارتبط
الامارات و بمشروعها اداره ميناء جيبوتي
كان
هذا الرجل وكان له دور كبير في اتمام
الصفقه ولذلك كان يريد ان يتولى اداره اه
بناء لكن اه وزير خارجيه ومالي الان اه في
تلك الفتره
اقترح ان يقضي الصباح
شركه برا له الجزئي وهي الشركه الفرنسيه
بدلا م والدمار وقد ثبت عن
الشركه مذكره التفاهم مع ارض الصومال في
فبراير عام الفين وثلاثه على ان يتم توقيع
اتفاق كامل
مايو من نفس العام
ومع ذلك لم تلتزم حكومه اقليم ارض الصومال
بمذكره التفاهم مع الشركه الفرنسيه
ومنحت امتياز ميناء بالشركه موانئ دبي في
اتفاقيه وصفت بالسريه فقد اخطا الرئيس
السابق ل ارض الصومال محمد احمد محمود
الملقب سيلانيو وثيقه الاتفاق الاصليه عن
برلمان ارض الصومال
وقدم بدلا منها ورقه بدون توقيع ومترجمه
الى اللغه الصوماليه علمت من مصادر حكوميه
مطلعه ان الرئيس محمد عبد الله فرماجه طلب
شخصيا ثلاث مرات من ولي عهد ابوظبي محمد
بن زايد الاطلاع على الاتفاق الاصلي لكن
طلبه قوبل بالرفض
الامر الذي اثار تساؤلات عن اسباب اخطاء
سيلانيو الوثيقه الاصليه اول شيء ما
متورط في هذه الصفقه ويقال انه
تلقى ملايين الدولارات من هذه الصفقه وكان
ممثل الصومال في الامارات في تلك الفتره
وكان اللاعب اساسي من اه لا باس فيه تنفيذ
هذه الاتفاقيه وكل الاجراءات المتعلقه
بهذا الاتفاق السبب الثاني هو ان هناك
الكثير من التنازلات لصالح الامارات هذا
جعل الرئيس ارض الصومال
لا يعرف الوثيقه الاساسيه التي تم التوقيع
عليها على البرلمان حتى بالبرلمان ناقش
على هذه هذه المساله اه بشكل كبير وحدثت
مشادات كلاميه بين اه يخص الوضع هل هناك
من عرب في ثماني لاند هذه الاتفاقيه مع
الامر اه نعم نعم من من من الشخصيات التي
عرضت واه يعني رئيس اكبر حزب سياسي الذي
ينافس
تنافس الانتخابات الاخيره مع الرئيس
الحالي وهو اه عبد الرحمان الذي هو يتراس
حزب الوطني وهو حزب كبير جدا حتى عندما
كان رئيسا
للبرلمان الصومالي الان ما كشف ان تم
مناقشه المواقع على هذه المساله اه عبد
الرحمان اه حدث بينه وبين اه نائب اخر اه
مشاده كلاميه
واشتباك بالايدي
الله
صحفي صوماليه اتهمت عددا من المسؤولين
السابقين في الحكومه الصوماليه وحكومه ارض
الصومال
وبرلمانيين سابقين بتلقي من الامارات
مقابل موافقتهم
بغض النظر عما اذا كانت هذه الادعاءات
صحيحه ام لا فقد اضفت مزيدا من الشكوك على
الاتفاقيه برمتها والكيفيه التي تمت بها
وعلاقه رئيس ارض الصومال السابق محمد
سيلانيو وعائلته بذلك عزز من هذه الشكوك
قيام فريق الرصد التابع للامم المتحده في
اريتيريا والصومال بفتح تحقيق في العقد
الممنوح لشركه موانئ دبي وما حوله من
شبهات فساد مالي من قبل عائله سيلانيو بما
في ذلك زوجته وصهره
توجهت الى وزير خارجيه الصومال احمد عوض
التي كان قد دعا شركه موانئ دبي الى
مراجعه عقدها مع ارض الصومال
والعمل مع الحكومه الفيدراليه لتطبيع
العلاقات بين مقديشيو ابو ظبي فيما يبدو
انها دعوه الى تقنين وضع الشركه
الاماراتيه وليس طردها نهائيا من الصومال
هل انتم منزعجون من الامارات لانكم لم
تكونوا جزء من اه الاتفاقيات لان الامارات
قامت الاتصال المباشر مع الاقاليم دون
الرجوع الحكومه الفيدراليه في مقديشو اه
مثل ما وضحنا
اعلن الاتفاقيه نحن قلنا نحن
نرحب
عمل تنوي
في اي
اقليم في الصومال اه لكن هذا لا يحصل الا
معرفه وموافقه ال
الحكومه ال ال فدراليه لكن هناك اثناء
صوماليه متورطه في التوقيع على هذه
الاتفاقيه شركه موانئ دبي لم تعلن ها دون
ان تاخذ او وضع اطار قانوني لها
نحن نعتبر هذه الاتفاقيه
وغير اه مبنيه على اه
قانوني هل حاولت السعوديه ان تلعب دور
الوسيط بين الصومال والامارات رغم موقفكم
المحايد من الازمه الخليجيه
السعوديين قالوا نحن ان نتدخل
ونحن غبن ما يعني رحبنا هذا فكان وعد انه
سيتدخل
[موسيقى]
سته سبعه شهور يعني
ما زلنا
صبورين حاول الموقف الرسمي الصومالي بنفسه
عن الازمه الخليجيه وحصر خلافه مع
الامارات بالوضع القانوني لشركه موانئ دبي
لكن على ما يبدو كانت انعكاسات الازمه
الخليجيه اكبر وساهمت في تفاقم الاحتكاك
بين مقديشو وزعماء الاقاليم البحريه ما
اعطي مثالا واضحا على تاثير الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه على دول القرن الافريقي
وسياساتها الداخليه والخارجيه
برلمان
المراه الاسباب الماليه او اقتصاديه
منفصله بينما تصل في مقديشو الاجانب قطر
وتركيا لذلك هناك فلتان نوع مختلف ان يضع
ان اللاعبين مختلفين بفرنسا بوتين في
فرنسا
بالنسبه للجهود قد اصبحت هدفا رئيسا
للامارات بسبب الرغبه في توسيع تجارتها
وسياستها الخارجيه البحريه
مين مصالحها الامنيه وبالمناسبه هذا الامر
ليس قاصرا على القرن الافريقي فقط فقد بدا
من ليبيا وموانيها ستجدين نفس اللاعبين
الدوليين يتنافسون ضد بعضهم البعض حتى في
ليبيا لذلك التنافس يبدا وليبيا وعلى طول
الطريق الى البحر الاحمر والمحيط الهندي
وحتى كيسمايو على طول الحدود مع كينيا انه
نفسي التنافس الذي حدث في القرن التاسع
عشر على القواعد العسكريه والموانئ يحدث
الان
ال ايران تحاول
عن محيط الكون بايجاد منافسين مثل اه اه
من
اه اه اه في الصومال وفي اريتريا هل
تعتقدون ان الهدف من انشاء موانئ في تلك
المناطق هو
الكويت جيبوتي
نعم هذا ليس لعزل جيبوتي فقط بل اعقاب
جيبوتي لذلك يقومون بما يقومون به الان
لانه كما اخبرتك سابقا لا حاجه لمشغل
ميناء ان يستحوذ على خمسه او سته او سبعه
موانئ في نفس المنطقه في خليج عدن والبحر
الاحمر
ليتنافسوا ضد بعضهم البعض
لكن دعهم يفعلون ذلك نحن مستعدون لهذا
النوع من المنافسه ولا نخاف منها سعداء
بالعمل في البحر الاحمر سواء في نشاط
اعاده الشحن او نقل البضائع للدول
المجاوره
كشف سباق القواعد العسكريه الاجنبيه في
القرن الافريقي كيف اصبحت صفقات الموانئ
التجاريه تقريبا مجرد مدخل لبناء تلك
القواعد الى جانب القواعد الاجنبيه في
جيبوتي وقواعد الامارات في كل من اريتيريا
واقليم ارض الصومال الانفصالي باتت لتركيا
اكبر قاعده عسكريه خارج حدودها في مقديشو
ودول اخرى في الطريق
وهو ما اكسب موانئ القرن الافريقي ابعادا
امنيه ليس فقط لموقعها الاستراتيجي بين
طرق التجاره البحريه ولكن ايضا لقربها من
الصراعات الاقليميه
ومع هذا السباق المحموم
تبدو منطقه القرن الافريقي ذاهبه الى مزيد
من العسكره والنفوذ الاجنبي على حساب
استقرار دول القرن لتتحول معه الى مجرد
ساحه لتقسيم النفوذ بين المتنافسين هذه لك
وهذه